this video is sponsored by Art list
subscribe today and get two months free
[Music]
so you may have seen one of the Fast and
Furious movies or maybe you've seen the
whole series but did you know how they
originally got their name back when they
were working on the very first film they
had a list of terrible titles but one
was sticking out the Fast and Furious
they said hey that's such a great title
the only problem is that there's already
a movie called The Fast and Furious it
was made in the 50s by Infamous B-movie
director Roger Corman so they set out to
find him and strike a deal they said hey
hey Raj what will it take for us to get
that title from you because we love it
so much and he said well how about you
give me access to Universal's stock
footage library and then you can have it
so they said deal they shook hands Roger
Corman walked off with his stock footage
the writers got the title The Fast and
the Furious and the rest is history so
as this huge franchise one of the
biggest in history is now finally coming
to an end we thought it would only be
fitting return it to its original form
stock footage
foreign
so the reason you're here is because you
guys are the best people at flipping
these franchises on their heads
everything from obviously the John Wick
Steven Seagal Batman with home alone
with Willy wonkas of the world and today
is a perfect opportunity for us to do a
fast and furious trailer editing
challenge the only caveat is once again
we have to use stock footage our list is
hooking up this video here so we're all
going to be able to use their stock
footage music sound effects everything
hey what yeah we have we're all gonna
have the unlimited accounts I mean this
video is literally sponsored by Art list
oh is it all those Like Remix edits that
me and Nick have done it's challenging
because you need to take a lot of
footage you're working with all these
movies and trying to fine-tune dial it
in Tell Your Own Story through them this
is I think possibly one of our greatest
challenges we've never waited this deep
into the stock no yeah we're going all
the way down to the trenches in terms of
like how are we going to illustrate Fast
and Furious it's like how do you not
illustrate Fast and Furious how do we
totally flip it using completely
different footage that's where I think
this challenge is going to be fun as an
editor the fast series is so ridiculous
and it's gotten weirder and weirder over
the course of the movies like one and
two were basically just street racing
movies you know plain and simple No
Frills nothing crazy but as the series
went on uh these movies became so balls
of the wall insane and I love it these
things have gotten me and my friends so
hyped and so amped that we're like
literally screaming in the theaters and
that's hard to do you know you can't
really say that about many movies I mean
do you want to just sit down and watch
all the movies real quick yeah let's
let's catch up let's let's watch let's
watch the whole series let's sleep on it
we'll watch it again tomorrow and then
let's meet here on Wednesday and we'll
do the challenge after we're done
editing these trailers I want you guys
to look your best and we'll join in
solitude to watch these and send off
this franchise I hope that after
watching this whole series twice it
doesn't change us as people and we all
remain true to ourselves but still have
the knowledge of the series let's do
this yeah we're gonna need it all right
three two one family
does this look like a man that's
stressed cool calm and collected baby
today is the day we have three editors
Sam Nick and Matt but they only have
three hours to come up with the best
possible Fast and Furious trailer using
only stock footage Ready Set eyeless
I'm starting with Fast and Furious
number nine there's a lot of talking in
the trailer which is nice
who is Dom's brother just a heads up
John Cena is Vin Diesel's brother Isn't
that cool he's his twin brother we can
take the trailers and take just the
audio of the vocals out Jacob is Dom's
brother
this is very funny we're honing in to
the reason people see these films and
it's because of that heartfelt family
drama family family family family family
family family family
family family
if there's anything that could bring
this family together I think it's a
little trip to America's best family
restaurant we're all family here I'm
gonna open up art list and start
snagging my b-roll I'm gonna do a quick
search for grilled shrimp and let art
lists AI starts to do its Fast and
Furious magic so now I'm very excited
there's like one shot that they have a
million different versions of and I'm
gonna try and use all of them no way
but for the sound design and all the
music we're going to be pulling that
from art lists Library as well
they have tons of stuff which is perfect
because I need a rustic Italian serenade
but also a very dramatic cinematic score
when you strike gold it's great uh
finally I finally know what I'm doing
now
I picked the trailer for Fast six
uh guys they got a tank specifically
because of one line of dialogue you
believe in ghosts do you believe in
ghosts The Fast and Furious family have
become Ghost Hunters and they have to
take down ghosts with their cars I'm
gonna see if I can get that to work with
stock footage we have some great shots
of ghouls I'm looking for bald men in
cars and there is a wide variety of all
men in cars there there's all kinds of
stuff I can work with here and this one
this one right here this is an 8K
personally we have that 8K highest
resolution bald man plan but say you
don't need AK well they have different
plans to fit your specific needs there
are lots of bald men in cars so this is
working
I am working with Tokyo Drift ready
so this movie was made long enough ago
you get the classic trailer voice guy
now in a place where life moves this
fast it was actually the title of the
film itself Tokyo Drift that gave me my
idea looking through ART list there's a
lot of footage of elderly people and if
there's one thing I know about elderly
people is they like to drift off to
sleep sometimes so now that I have all
my old people I need the cars that they
are dreaming of so I just found a shot
of a high-speed Zoom through a tunnel at
night this footage is clearly shot by
someone who knows what they're doing and
then it's delivered in a variety of
professional codecs you can download
quicktimes MP4s I'm trying to find like
some moments where I can like match
mouth movements of the people I'm
finding so I can have some real
characters talking it's going to make it
feel like a real movie if I can match up
the lips just even a little bit
and we've done it three trailers in
three hours and if you're an editor you
know that's no small feat but if you
want the superpower for yourself click
the link in the description below to
sign up for art list where they have all
the stock footage assets you could ever
need now let's cross that finish line
[Music]
yeah yeah so uh We've gathered here
today to uh send off this series uh so
yeah you know I never really knew the
Fast and Furious series very well I only
watched two of the movies you know but I
thought they're really cool uh you know
you know and the first one really made a
big impact on me because the thing is
there is a glue that connects all these
films you know family
the world has the way of changing and we
changed too
[Music]
who is he Jacob is
Dom's brother
not today
it's been a long time
never turn you back on family
turned you back on me now your little
family is n't my bro
[Music]
I spent my entire life in your you
spend the rest of yours put it in mind
your own private Army we need help we're
gonna need more shrimp
okay
when you're here you're my family
really duct tape you acting like we on
our way to Home Depot
shrimp
cool it was absolutely touching Sam
thank you thank you thank you for that
yeah wow I don't know how I can follow
that up because it was perfect eulogy it
really just all encompasses the
franchise it's family it's shrimp it's
meals it's it just works if this series
kept going like this inevitably would be
the intersection between culinary you
know experiences and Blockbuster Cinema
that we've always wanted okay rip rip
well
let me just say this
friends family that is what it's all
about the movies brought my friends and
family together as well we all were in a
theater dying laughing at these
ridiculous stupid stupid films and I
love them I want to showcase what they
could be going forward
it's 100 million buys huh
wasn't that hard to find you Toretto
listen Heidi
this was taken a week ago
I need your help Don I need your team
got the best crew in the world standing
right in front of you this is not what
we do we're not dealing with cops we're
drug dealers I've never seen this before
you believe in ghosts
it didn't let him be once he was gone
[Music]
you're talking vehicular Warfare uh
gospel they got a tank
[Laughter]
ghosts and ghouls wow is sort of the
angle it's amazing thank you I just have
to say like it's really incredible how
how authentic that feels and how true it
feels to the original path I think
you're you're working your shot
selection yes to make sure that like
even though they're gone you know the
cast is gone the series is gone it
really feels like they are still here
with us which is there was a wide
selection of bald beefcakes for me to
choose from and um yeah that that really
tied the piece together you know Tokyo
Drift the question is you know where
where do we drift off to when it all
ends what happens when we take our final
drift
ready set up
go
[Music]
it's called drifting what do you mean
drill cause of life
when we drift if you ain't out of
control you ain't in control
still need a dictionary
other side of the world a new style of
racing rules the underground how do you
guys get away with this
all the best stripers want in who's a
tourist let's see what the kids got no
less rice
[Music]
anything can happen in the wrong place
now in a place where life moves this
fast it's a lot of money the bigger the
risk the greater the rush all my life
people tell me I don't fit in maybe I've
just been in the wrong place
[Music]
I'm single make choices don't look back
oh oh
that was too real man that hits home
wow you took the drifting and brought
out a whole new meeting but I was
curious if they were dying or going to
bed because it seems like they'd do a
little bit of both what do you think I
guess
that's why it's art yeah ashes to ashes
stock footage to stock footage okay
let's be honest that was hilarious yes
that was actually really really fun nice
job guys I was cracking up the whole
time I was editing mine I don't know
about you guys but it was a little
stressful but ultimately I I would love
to do that again guys let us know which
trailer did you like the most and of
course we do have to thank artless for
making this whole thing possible they
gave us access to their entire Library
so we could create this and I mean
honestly it was really great using those
assets it was really easy and it was
really really fun it Unleashed our
creativity seriously that's all we have
to say don't forget to subscribe thanks
a lot for watching peace